jurors in kyle rittenhouse's murder
trial heard gripping testimony yesterday
the 18 year old killed two people during
black lives matter protest in kenosha
wisconsin last year rittenhouse says he
was defending himself yesterday's
testimony came from a man who was shot
after he confronted rittenhouse with a
gun nancy chen is outside the courthouse
in kenosha with more on this story nancy
good morning
gail good morning to you the prosecution
has been trying to prove that
rittenhouse initiated the confrontations
that led him to shoot three men two who
died in a third gauge gross crates who
survived
i thought that the defendant was an
active shooter
in court monday jurors watched video of
the moment kyle rittenhouse shot gage
gross kroitz with an ar-15 style rifle
what was going through your mind at this
particular moment
that i was going to die grosskroyd says
he was shot in the arm and lost 90
percent of his bicep that looks like my
bicep being vaporized the jury also
watched never before seen drone video of
when rittenhouse shot and killed another
man joseph rosenbaum when grosskroyd's
heard the gunshots he says he ran toward
them and approached rittenhouse with his
own gun drawn i was never trying to kill
the defendant
gross kreutz claims his hands were
raised when rittenhouse aimed his rifle
at him that moment
i was trying to preserve my own life
the defense told a different story
arguing rittenhouse felt threatened by
gross kreutz and acted in self-defense
when you were standing three to five
feet from him it wasn't until you
pointed your gun at him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
that he fired right
correct
defense attorney joe tambourino who
isn't connected to the case says gross
croise's testimony is key for both sides
because on the one hand you have someone
who was shot and suffered a great deal
on the other hand you have mr
rittenhouse who was 17 years old at the
time and who was facing someone with a
gun when he fired you have a witness who
could be used by either side and he's
very compelling gross quotes maintained
he never planned to shoot anyone that's
not the kind of person that i am
it's not who i am
and definitely
not somebody that i
would want to become
and rittenhouse could testify in the
next couple days as the defense begins
its case if convicted of homicide he
could face life in prison nate
nancy thank you